Speaker 1: Let's go next to Bert from New
Jersey. Bert from New Jersey. Welcome.
Please save us. Let's hope your connection
is better than the last two have been.
Speaker 5: You, David. How's my connection?
Speaker 1: It's beautiful so far.
Speaker 5: Awesome. Awesome.
Thanks for picking on me. Pleasure.
Here is my question. When people criticize
Biden. Yes. From the right. Typically. Right.
First, they talk about inflation. This is Biden's
economy. Biden's inflation by inflation rate.
The very nature of how inflation occurs
is you increase the money supply. Right.
So Trump in four years increased the money supply
more than any U.S. president in the history of
our country in a four year span. Right. So my
my question is, why don't people call that out
where we're okay, you're your guest. Inflation
will. How are you for Trump trumping that?
Speaker 1: Well, increasing the money supply,
depending on how it's done and for what purposes
can have an inflationary effect, that is not a
guarantee that it does. So I think at least we
on the left want to be a little more precise
with with that and tactical in terms of when
when we when we bring it up. But you're right
that at least as far as the right is concerned,
that is true. And listen, this is not new
ground in the sense that I've said before
when Republicans say that Biden's
COVID stimulus caused inflation,
Trump did two of the stimulus or stimuli, as
well as PPIP, which became a fraudulent slush
fund. So the I think the way I would approach it
is, aside from debating the money supply issue,
if you blame Biden, you have to blame Trump at
least two times more because he did two of the
COVID stimulus packages. And of course they
don't because they don't actually care or no.
It's just about what can I get away with saying
and who can I criticize? Who's on the left?
Speaker 5: Right. Maybe my plan is not the right
word. What I'm really getting at is deficits.
Right. Trump had an $8 trillion
budget deficit in four years.
Right. That gets funded not through borrowing
money, Not through raising taxes, through just
training money supply. Right. That alone has a
huge catastrophic effect on inflation. It's no
coincidence it started when Trump is leaving.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I think that, you know,
they're modern monetary theorists disagree with
that premise and are working hard to explain to
us that that's not actually the case. Let where
I will leave it is you're absolutely right in
assessing the conventional wisdom around a lot
of these issues. And Republicans are complete
hypocrites in their ignoring of it as it
pertains to Trump. 100%. Right on that.
Speaker 5: Right. Right. So you said you
can't be a New York Giants and a Philadelphia
Eagles fan at the same time. It's like.
Speaker 1: I guess not. I guess not. That
sounds tough. Yeah. All right, Bert, thank
you for the call. I appreciate it. Thank you,
David. All right. There is Bert from Jersey.
Great to hear from you. Why don't we go next
to a treatise from Boston? A treatise
from Boston? Welcome. What's going on?
Speaker 6: Hey, David. So I
had a question about Florida.
Speaker 1: Okay.
Speaker 6: Okay. So it's no secret that,
I mean, DeSantis won by the highest gubernatorial
margin in Florida history. I think it was 1.5
million votes. And in his four years of in elected
offices, especially in the last couple of years,
been basically drunk with power, you know, with
the don't say yay, Bill. Yep. The gerrymandering,
a whole list of things. And just recently
you talked about how he wanted to or at least
the state Senate wanted to ban the Democratic
Party from Florida. Yep. Now, he wanted to ban
journalists from criticizing him. In fact, I was
just listening to your colleague Farron Cousins,
last night saying that he who lives in Florida is
considering moving because of this. I basically
wanted to ask the broad question, is Florida
beyond saving at this point, or do you think
the pendulum is going to swing back at some point?
Speaker 1: No, I wouldn't say Florida is beyond
saving, because what you have to remember
is that the number of Democrats in Florida
is insanely high as a result of the fact
that Florida's population is so large. And
although that margin certainly was was a
record record for for the governor's race,
I would not in any way think about abandoning
Florida. I think Florida is a project where it
has certainly started to lean more red than it
was, you know, in the Bush era, for example.
But I would I would be I think it would be
a disastrous idea for Democrats to abandon
it. I think it's a great opportunity. The
pendulum does often swing back. And I mean,
listen, if DeSantis became president, it could
create a vacuum in Florida that could actually
be really good for Democrats. I think it
would be a very bad idea to say we're not
we're not thinking about Florida anymore.
Speaker 6: Yeah, I'm kind of in the same
boat as you. I just. I hear a lot of talk of It's
time to let Florida go. No, no. In the same way,
like. Yeah, No, I agree with you. I
mean, it has. From what I understand,
the fourth highest LGBT population, it's a state
that Obama won twice, has a very high person,
person of color population. So. Yeah, I
agree with you that it's not beyond saving.
I just think there's there's definitely a lot of
panic among the left. Yeah. What to do? Florida.
Speaker 1: Let's not panic and let's keep working
because I think it's a it would be a huge mistake
to give it up. A treatise from Boston. Great to
hear from you today. I do appreciate it very much.